[Musique]
christophe qui est l'un des le dira l'un
des pères fondateurs de la bd essais par
contraste avec tous ces nouveaux héros
de la bd que vous invitez caradec pour
parler effectivement de la biographie de
christophe tout sous titre du livre
génial auteur d'immortels chef-d'oeuvre
c'est vrai le sapeur camember la famille
fenouillard le savant cosinus alors j'ai
donc découvert en lisant cette
biographie que c'était presque un savant
c'était un bon c'était un esprit
scientifique c'est un professeur un
botaniste c'était pas un personnage
sérieux du tout il est évident qu'être
sous directeur du laboratoire de
botanique de la sorbonne sous le nom de
colomb et puis choisir le pseudonyme de
christophe oui c'est déjà ce les chasser
hors c'est une plaisanterie normalien
mais quand même
[Musique]
pauvre petit oiseau sur la brume
entre le ciel que ce qui est frappant
c'est que chaque fois que relie jury
voilà il est au milieu d'un carrefour
d'influencés l'influencé junte a donc il
son rôle et rennes me semble très
important
j'avais 8 ans quand ils me faire ça j'ai
fait un peu la gueule cheveux soient
vraiment très très très noir très
difficile avait pas de bulle juste les
jusque et moi je disais quand même déjà
un peu de bande dessinée mais j'ai quand
même je suis quand même entrer dedans et
[Musique]
et ça m'a vachement plus
et vous monsieur georges colomb vos
souvenirs de lecture
mon père m'avait d'abonnés à une de ses
publications destinées à instruire et en
même temps à regret la jeunesse
française
mais j'avoue amar honte que ces belles
choses me laissait alors assez
indifférent pour la raison qu'elle est
passée singulièrement la portée de ma
jeune intelligence
j'aurais volontiers donné quatre ans
d'abonnement pour une vingtaine l'image
d'epinal j'avais mauvais goût je le
confesse
mais peut-être aussi ne savions pas où
nous étions pas alors écrire pour les
enfants simplement des choses simples et
le 19e s'est lentement la constitution
d'un domaine spécifique des publications
pour les enfants on commence à prendre
l'enfance pour un monde spécifique avec
l'enfant est un une personne
particulière avec des besoins
particuliers ce n'était pas du tout
perçue avant on est à l'époque de jules
ferry scolarisation obligatoire
développement exponentiel de
l'alphabétisation découverte d'un public
il faut dire aussi d'un marché jeunes
une certaine façon on invente la
jeunesse à cette époque là c'est tout à
fait sérieuses et pas une formule en
l'air et ce public là on va lui proposer
des manuels scolaires
là c'est l'état qui contrôle les rames
en colin joue son jeu avec d'autres de
la grave
hachette terrain et puis on va lui
proposer des journaux mais des ça
n'existe pas c'est vrai c'est rien c'est
juste des petites fantaisies de
dessinateurs qui font preuve à travers
on considère généralement que te faire
est l'inventeur de la bande dessinée
moderne parce que c'est lui que l'idée
de la séquence et quand on veut définir
ce qu'est une bande dessinée on en
revient surtout à l'idée de l'histoire
avec une séquence d'image
monsieur top faire a écrit ce petit
livre est d'une nature mixte il se
compose d'une série de dessins
photographiés ou très chacun de ses
dessins est accompagné d'une ou deux
lignes de texte les dessins sans ce
texte n'aurait qu'une signification
obscures le texte sans les dessins ne
signifierait rien le tous ensemble
forment une sorte de rendement c'est de
la littérature en estampe que ce soit
fût il est évident à travers tout faire
il reprenait puisque une citation de
topher en exergue les familles à ryton
des choses spirituelles comme des
grosses bêtises que dicte une folle
gaieté
c'est douteux expression esprit ça
fatigue bêtise sur bêtise hadopi il
était très très gai et raconter toujours
des histoires est d'ailleurs toujours on
parle des gais lurons
il était de lui en fait la lurons donc
monsieur christophe vous vous appelez
georges colomb vous êtes né en 1856 à
lure en haute-saône et votre père était
directeur du collège
vous avez eu une éducation c'est vous
quand j'étais tout petit mes parents
m'avaient placé sous l'autorité et la
férule du maître d'école de chez nous
quelque chose comme un instituteur à
l'état larvaire
mais lorsque nous sortions de cema nous
savions à peu près tout ce qu'il savait
lui même c'est à dire lire écrire et
calculer en géographie la grande affaire
était d'apprendre par coeur les 89
départements français savoir son
histoire consistait à connaître sans
broncher les noms et les dates de toutes
les batailles qui avait ensanglanté le
monde nous ignorions complètement les
conquêtes sociales de la révolution
aussi l'annoncent d'un conflit possible
entre la france plus
mutel d'autre effet que de nous faire
dire enfin ce n'est pas trop tôt les en
1870 les prussiens envahissent l'est et
l'eures
et c'est là que vous avez connu le
modèle du sapeur camember le sapeur
camember ils s'en moquent pas en réalité
c'est un personnage très sympathique
déjà cette époque là il y avait plus de
sa peur après la guerre de 70 alors pour
lui c'était déjà un petit peu
folklorique c'était un peu parlé de sa
jeunesse et et d'affolter de sa jeunesse
un soir en études j'étais en sixième à
l'abri d'un dictionnaire latin grands
ouverts je lisais subrepticement les
aventures du sapeur camember pendant que
monsieur garnier les assauts journal au
ski ona cancrelats du camembert tu ma
fille tu là qu'a commencé par anne où et
quand a les reins à l'autre qui sera
tout et pratt et d'avoir fini le code
votre système simple se remonte il est
bigrement long je ne colle fait que la
moitié au creux là bas donc des jeunes
avaient dans la cervelle hoyaux
réfléchissons à tubize où on finit le
sait les bûches deux bouts si ça oui à
ce bout si y'a plus une bûche espèces de
moules c'est parle ou debout qu'il
fallait commencer par ce cas présent
qu'il n'y a plus rien debout si si
teulet commencer par au bout il te reste
plus rien à faire sans le savoir je
faisais de petits rires qui finirent par
attirer l'attention de monsieur garnier
il se leva soudain main vers moi et
motta mon livre des mains d'un seul coup
d'oeil il identifia camembert des heures
de retenue
c'est cette espèce de d'exotisme de
l'histoire tu exactement comme comme
tintin c'est pourtant au golf ou spirou
avec ça son uniforme de groom
je veux qu'un dessinateur qu'il dit est
de faire un chapeau
cette fois lui comme ça et rosso singh
super mid et mon revers face à ma
nouvelle victoire faudrait tirer les
jours sur du colonel monsieur k montre
en deux temps trois mouvements ça va
être fait même une victoire seulement
que j'aurais désirer que le service il
serait plus conséquent camembert
chantant je ne chante pas petit oiseau
qui êtes dans le feuillage
[Musique]
dussault
et bien sympathique monsieur gamin c'est
à dire mam'zelle victoire que ça serait
comme qui dirait le miroir de la beauté
si vous vous garderiez dodo picore mes
chaussures voilà mon colonel
mais incorrigible tête de bois tu ne
vois pas que tu me donnes une paire
départ et fait excuser mon colonel film
austin mais que je vous ferai observé
avec tout mon respect que l'autre perd
elle n'est pas plus pareilles et que
celle ci c'est d'une logique et d'une
création verbale tout à fait étonnante
moi je trouve ça c'est une autre façon
de voir la réalité en 1878 vous intégrer
l'école normale supérieure à paris
là vous côtoyez jaurès bergson et
baudrillard votre petite fille hélène a
écrit que vous avez joué à pile ou face
entre sciences et lettres votre entrée
rue d'ulm mais aussi peut-être avez-vous
fait ce choix parce qu'on y dessiner
toujours est il que vous goûté à l'or à
la vie parisienne
paris est un peu la capitale
intellectuelle du monde mais aussi ne se
prend pas complètement au sérieux il
faut mettre vie parisienne
et puis c'est la république c'est donc
une vraie liberté d'expression
christophe est un
contemporain alors parfois on a la
preuve qu'il est fréquente est parfois
on peut supposer qu'ils l'elysée mais ce
qui compte c'est l'ambiance générale de
ces humoristes
vingt siècles qui encore aujourd'hui
peuvent être lues de penser à alphonse
allais bien sûr tout ce qui tourne
autour du chat noir et de quelques
autres revues et cabaret hydropathes etc
il faut saluer charles cros c'est un
grand inventeur et au moment où
christophe de lens je sais s'ils n'en
abuse pas de cette liberté
vous avez la loi la plus libérale la loi
de 1881 plus libéré aujourd'hui
mais au fait comment avez vous commencé
si j'ai dessiné ce fut par 10 par
distraction
[Musique]
j'avais un ami dans une grande maison
d'édition
je lui demandais s'il ne pourrais pas me
trouver quelque chose a illustré chez
lui la réponse qui me saoule je devais
n'en recevoir partout où je me
présentais pour travailler ici il faut
avoir débuté ailleurs je finis par
trouver un éditeur pour ne prendre mes
dessins il ne les paient pas et les
trouver parfait il a écrit ses histoires
pour son fils pour mon père qui a perdu
sa mère à 8 ans et qui était donc élevée
par son père et pour l'amuser il a créé
sa et un jour je ne sais pas si c'est
lui qui les a montrés armand colin ou
butoir en colin qui il a su je ne sais
pas comment ça s'est passé
je fut remarqué par armand colin qui
était un homme étonnant il me commande à
quelque chose pour l'exposition de 1889
je lui donnais la famille fenouillard à
l'exposition pour le petit français
illustrée
c'est sans doute pas un hasard si la
famille fenouillard qui s'appelle
d'ailleurs d'abord la famille cornillet
et qui est parisienne et qui deviendra
fenouillard provincial permet des effets
comiques supplémentaire est lancée à
l'occasion de l'exposition universelle
de 1889 la grande exposition qui nous a
donné la tour eiffel à partir damien la
famille commence à interroger l'horizon
dans l'espoir d'y découvrir la tour
eiffel on entre vraiment dans une ère de
d'entousiasme d'optimisme on dirait
technologiques aujourd'hui et la famille
fenouillard on est un peu le témoignage
parce que colomb devenant christophe est
à la fois un savant meehan ironiste et
il va retourner cette technique qui va
retourner ses connaissances
scientifiques ça donnera aussi caussinus
dans peu de temps
dans un sens toujours comique c'est à
dire qu'il saura prendre ses distances à
l'égard de ce culte de la technique dont
monsieur fenouillard agenor toujours
pontifiant le côté joseph prud'hommes
est attachante
donc il a effectivement cette idée que
on peut faire le tour du monde sur
quelques hectares au bord de la seine
mais évidemment le coup de génie en fait
de christophe c'est imaginer que cette
famille va être obligé de faire vraiment
le tour du monde sans y être préparé les
gosses en redemande r ils voulaient
savoir ce que devenait lé fenouillard
j'avais passé mes vacances à saint malo
gic obliger les fenouils
il ne fallut leur faire faire le tour de
monde j'obéissais à la clientèle je dois
vous dire que je m'amuse follement est
le premier étonné du succès de mes
dessins c'était moi
[Musique]
en amérique hurle tankers tous les
fenouillard un amérique
nous allons en amérique n'est pas du
possible à moins qu avant d'arriver d'un
coquine et coulé à pic alors nos
voyageurs malgré déjà fortement secoué
par tant d'émotions diverses
accablé par ce dernier coup du sort
s'évanouissent dans s'écriant christophe
colomb soit maudit il y a eu dès
l'antiquité un voyage parodique était
lucien de samosate après guerre
rappelait il y a
les voyages que font les comédiens de
scarron et tout ça ce sont des auteurs
liés au burlesque à l'héroïque comique
il y a évidemment au cyrano de bergerac
c'est le voyage dans la lune et le
soleil il y à candide et candide qui
n'est pas sans rapport avec fenouillat
parce que candide part avec une idée
précise du monde
lui c'est qu'ils résument à une formule
1 tout est pour le mieux dans le
meilleur des mondes
or fenouillard par lui avec une série de
préjugés il a des formules toutes faites
sur ce qu'il va voir
lesieu fenouillard juge opportun de
donner quelques conseils sur la façon
dont on doit se tenir pour avoir l'air
tout à fait japonaise et par cela même
en imposer à ces peuplades sauvage et
peu civilisé madame fenouillat ironique
fait tout cette remarque que pour
appartenir à des peuplades sauvage voilà
des gens qui semblent singulièrement
civilisé quant à monsieur fenouillard il
est quelque peu interloqués cependant à
la vue de quelques indigènes encore plus
japonais que lui et entrant dans une
maison gardé par un soldat de paravent
monsieur fenouillard retrouve son
assurent quant à vous le disais tout à
coup pour son d'une musique guerrière se
mettent à défiler des militaires vêtue à
l'europe et pas d'arbre devient ironique
l'intelligence de monsieur comment
sarah ciller mais voilà qu'à leur tour
ils pénètrent dans la maison des anneaux
mais des gens idéalement japonais alors
madame cesse d'être ironique
monsieur fenouillard n'éprouve aucune
honte à se déclarer un lui même qui n'y
comprend plus rien bahia le langage
bourgeois le langage de la culture
classique mal assimilé le langage du
cliché rhétorique à peine délivrée
monsieur fenouillat ramassent quelques
armes sur le champ de bataille est
suivie de sa famille il se des remparts
une prompte fuite au hasard des combats
là on est dans la lèque 120 racinien
vous avez aussi en même temps le langage
scientifique procédant alors par
analogie résumant par induction puis par
déduction monsieur fenouillard on arrive
à conclure que s'il a été retardé dans
sa marche et qu'il existe une cause
retarda trice
et puis vous avez l'antiphrase par
exemple s'étant noblement retourner pour
prendre courageusement la fuite
c'est à dire que le langage qui est
d'habitude réservé pour raconter les
exploits des héros le ton épique les
grandes figures de rhétorique les
grandes phrases et rythmes ternaires etc
les belles métaphores les
personnification sont ici appliqué à des
des gens ordinaires à des aventures
mesquine trivial de tous les jours à du
quotidien après discussion on a décidé
qu'on irait à bruxelles pour voir le
musée d'un verre qui est un revolver
chargé au coeur de l'angleterre comme a
dit jules césar
on voit que monsieur fenouillard
aime à citer les mots célèbres c'est la
frappe l'imagination et l'aide de lames
et réchauffe le coeur mais je me
souviens que la queue
hmm hmm hmm petit je vivais de l'ironie
dans le texte c'était et c'est un texte
où ils ont pied on poulet et que c'était
il y avait des effets comiques
je pensais une citation formidable
monsieur fenouillard pensait comme
montaigne qu'il n'a pas reconnu que
l'oisiveté elle a une belle sentence
et ça c'est très drôle c'est du non
d'humour presque connaissent et ont à
l'université votre double personnalité
de professeurs et d'auteurs pour enfants
ah c'était le secret de polichinelle ne
se trouvent at-il pas un inspecteur
pourra les rapporter au recteur que je
n'étais qu'un vulgaire caricaturiste
l'auteur de la famille fenouillard conte
à 2,26 à la famille fenouillard
répondent-ils recteur créer c'est un
livre que je voudrais bien avoir écrit
dans les années 1880 à l'époque où
georges colomb on rentre comme boursier
au muséum
il a la chance par rapport à d'autres
avoir une bourse de thèse pour
travailler avec van tieghem philippe van
tieghem la thèse dans laquelle se lance
georges colomb elle et elle est en tous
les cas très importante
il va définir un terme qui le stipulent
avec des fonctions anatomiques avec des
descriptions qui sont qui seront
reconnus très rapidement comme étant
quelque chose sur lesquels il faut baser
les critères de détermination et en tous
les cas interpréter la tige est là et la
feuille des plantes dont qui prend les
caractères des vaisseaux et en montrant
que c'est une dérivation du vaisseau de
la tige les vaisseaux de la tige et non
pas une dérivation des vaisseaux de fun
à peine caussinus at-il fait dit pas
dans les ruines qui les découvrent une
véritable forêt vierge et une flore
abondante et variée
puis il fait en herbe horizon
d'intéressantes découvertes zoologique
pour lesquels ils oublient la botanique
mais il y revient à la vue d'une espèce
nouvelle je l'appellerai labrihe osséja
parisianiste br après quoi
grâce à un concours fortuit de
circonstance il abandonne zoologie et
botanique pour se livrer à l'étude de la
chute des corps
christophe était botaniste mais qu aux
innus sont à son objet de dérision
visiblement et mathématicien qui plus
est
et ça ça se voit dès les premières pages
je reprends ouvrages et première page
alors c'est fear un brioché reçu une
bonne éducation
on montre ses talents mathématiques et
veuves voilà nous efira et avait avait
comme polytechnique la première école du
monde comme chacun sait il est bon de
remarquer que chaque école est considéré
comme la première du monde par tous ceux
qui en sont sortis ça faisait partie un
petit peu de cette tradition
nord-mayenne
d'autodérision parce que en se moquant
d'un mathématicien polytechnicien il se
moquait aussi de lui même et de ses
condisciples et j'ai trouvé fantastique
qu'on puisse faire une histoire sur
quelqu'un qui n'arrivait pas à faire
quelque chose là aussi c'est de l'humour
en creux l'idée fixe du savant cosinus
c'est un voyage qui n'existe pas
puisqu'il n'arrive pas à sortir de paris
avec évidemment toute une série de 2,2
de quiproquos très simple un beau matin
l'illustrent docteur caussinus se
réveilla avec une douleur lancinante
dans la moitié droite de la mâchoire à
ferry ayant établi certains axiome
servant de base quelques calculs simples
caussinus découvre que cette douleur
lancinante est vraisemblablement causée
par un mal de dents
à 2h52 le docteur caussinus sommes
exactes pénétrer dans le salon vide de
clients du dentiste max hilaire ce qui
lui fait espérer qu'il n'attendrait pas
longtemps l'âme des hommes de science
est nécessairement candide et elle donne
asile à deux mousses trop d'illusions à
7h33 le docteur attendait encore il est
vrai qu'il ne s'ennuyait pas absorbés
qu'ils étaient dans la lecture des hauts
faits de son cousin
agenor fenouillard et de son illustre
famille voyez vous cette lecture des
aventures de la famille fenouillard est
décisive le docteur pause innus il y
apprit d'abord lé envie de voyager qui
va devenir une idée fixe
il y a pris ensuite à un tel plaisir
qu'il a oublié qu'il était chez le
dentiste
ayant oublié son mal il a oublié qu'il
est chez le dentiste plus tôt ayant
oublié que les chez le dentiste
ils se croient chez lui et a l'aspect
d'une dame qui entrent ils se lèvent et
la reçoit madame lebaye lazor crois donc
puisque caussinus a oublié qu'il était
chez le dentiste
quand elle rentre chez elle dans tisme
caussinus lui fait les honneurs du salon
et lorsqu'elle lui dit j'ai là à une
douloureuse racines à extraire docteur
caussinus éclater de joie une extraction
de racine écrit le mathématicien c'est
ma spécialité ce matin même j'en ai
réussi une fort compliqué ici prend
place un dialogue absurde par quels
procédés désirez vous que je perds mais
monsieur dit adam parr celui qui me fera
le moins de mal au madame souris
caussinus je perds toujours sans douleur
mais puisque vous me laissez le choix
nous allons si vous le voulez bien
employer les tableaux garric
à ces mots madame b la zorn le fameux
dentiste à cause d'une série de
quiproquos et soupçonnait d'être où il
est enfermé et devient réellement fou et
à la face c'est lui qui veut plomber la
danse du midi avec le plomb du cantal et
il envisage même de poser à râteliers un
dentier sur les bouches du rhône
ça peut paraître du mauvais jeu de mots
même max hilaire
dentiste mais c'est très drôle quand on
est gosse ça marche très très bien
[Musique]
reccord scolastique leur corps comme l'a
fort de dyarchie med dont savant
collègues de l'université de syracuse
dans une circonstance analogues
seulement il était moins laitue que moi
il venait de prendre un bain complet
cette parole détermine la fuite rapide
de scholastic saisie de la crainte qu'il
ne prenne fantaisie à son illustre m de
se mettre dans le costume d'archimède
lorsqu'il découvrit l'immortel principes
dont il a l'honneur de porter le nom
d'ailleurs qu'on va même pas dire en
fonction du principe d'archimède
mais on va inverser même lac su faire un
jeu de de jeu savant un jeu de rudy un
jeu age moqueur à jeu typiquement
normani un cagnard un jeu sur la culture
ça c'est ça c'est une blague classique
des normaliens et des khâgneux archimède
celui qui porte le nom d'un célèbre
principe et non pas le principe qui
porte le nom du savant on trouve des tas
de choses que l'auteur n'a certainement
pas ok l'automne a certainement pas
pensé mais des concepts qui ont trouvé à
ce moment là leur place dans le
raisonnement scientifique on on trouve
la relativité on trouve validation des
particules d'un certain nombre de deux
choses comme ça encore une fois que nous
remettons nous mêmes mais c'est une
façon de lire ses ouvrages je connais
pas beaucoup d'autres ouvrages d'enfants
qu'on puisse revenir de cette façon à
vrai dire mais surpiqué bloc
voilà bien de farfadets qui ne risque
pas de se faire oublier alors messieurs
toujours à l'affût d'une bêtise voyons
donc quel est le malicieux forfait que
vous avez commis cette fois ci qu'est ce
que c'est que cette grosse boule là bas
sous la table interroge ploc
ça répond plique c'est une machine fait
exprès pour distraire les gnomes qui
s'ennuient clic
ah décidément une tendance à s'imaginer
que tout a été créé pour son amusement
personnel tiens ça descend quand on
tient la ficelle à temps on va bien
s'amuser et la flamme monte monte
et quand la grosse boule va brûler ce
sera très joli malheureusement les
gnomes ça ne s'est pas l'achat ignore
que les ballons se gonfle avec un gaz
nommé hydrogène et qui est la détestable
habitude de faire patard à pau quand on
en approche une flamme
[Musique]
commencez-vous par dessiner ou par
écrire je dessinais d'abord mais après
m'être fait une idée de la page dans son
ensemble
voulez-vous que je vous donne un secret
pour amuser les enfants fait du dialogue
les enfants aiment le dealer le dessin
est essentiel c'est christophe non c'est
pas du tout l'accessoire du texte on
peut parfois même voir le texte comme au
compteur à l'accessoire du dessin
d'ailleurs il a fait des histoires sans
paroles devaient prendre un grand
plaisir à dessiner parce que c'est
toujours extrêmement chiadé tout en
étant simple bien tintin quatre
personnages il y avait beaucoup d'idées
dans leur seront milieu pour c'est pas
du tout répétitif fois quant à son
dessin c'est un dessin qui est
relativement académique il n'a rien de
particulier sauf quand même l'exception
très notable c'est que christophe va
être le premier à utiliser d'état
d'angles de vue qui que personne n'avait
utilisé dans les histoires en images
avant lui il ya cette extraordinaire
images de l'omnibus vu d'en haut dans la
famille fenouillard il se place
carrément au dessus
comme toujours les fenouillard sont
supérieurs aux événements mais un
passant ayant aperçu en l'air quelque
chose d'insolite s'arrête aussi tôt
deux passants font autant puis trois
puis quatre puis 25
qui s'empresse d'examiner la chose
insolite puise une multitude qui
persistent à regarder en l'air
longtemps après que la chose insolite a
disparu le la plongée verte verticale il
semble bien que ce soit christophe dans
la famille fenouillard qui soit le
premier dessinateur au monde à
l'utiliser il joue aussi beaucoup pour
montrer l'envolée des personnages on ne
voit que les pieds dans la case une
chute
on ne voit que le postérieur et les
jambes qui sont coupées par le bas de la
case ils coupent énormément en faisant
même des cases pratiquement vides de
temps en temps des réminiscences de
daumier par exemple
exemple de caricaturistes dans ses
influences va plus influencé christophe
honoré daumier qui dans les années 1840
à dessiner une série de
de dessin pour les sabots pour rire
avec des procédés de petit peu amusant
de huy couper les sujets là c'est une
ascension jésus-christ où on ne voit que
les buts du pied du christ qui s'élève
et les le bout des lances dans la partie
inférieure du tableau
ces cases noires par exemple quand il
tombe dans un trou quand il est mis au
cachot ce qui lui arrive assez souvent
les filles et la mer fenouillard se
retrouve dans une pièce complètement
sombre donc on a pour illustration une
case complètement sombré il faut savoir
qu'à l'époque de christophe il y avait
un phénomène artistique s'appelait des
arcanes incohérent qui reprenait un
petit peu aussi satimo qui aurait pu par
exemple le logis de nuit pour se moquer
d'un tableau très sombre
le plus célèbre qu'ils ont concouru et
encore ce sont les monochromes de
alphonse allais lui qui s'amusait à à
exposer des deux cartons de couleur
unique monochrome donc noir rouge et
bleu et auxquels il donnait des titres
très évocateur donc pour le noir c'était
combat de dans un tunnel la nuit
donc voilà on retrouvait donc cesser ses
tableaux à vous savez son contemporain
de kristof il va être vraiment être
extrêmement moderne puisqu'il va
également être un des pionniers de du
travelling du panoramique et même de la
caméra subjective et les angles de vue
qui vont être ensuite utilisées parfois
dix vingt ans plus tard par le cinéma
[Musique]
avec les frères lumière et n'est pas a
reconnu le fait qu'ils étaient
influencés par une bande dessinée
christophe est l'auteur d'une courte
histoire de quelques images ça fait six
images pense que c'est en fait le
prototype de l'arroseur arrosé qui va
devenir le premier film de fiction de
l'histoire du cinéma
on sait que christophe s'est inspiré
d'une autre bd de l'arroseur arrosé paru
aussi l'imagerie quentin de son camarade
de connaître qui est hermann google est
la question qui se pose c'est qui c'est
qui a inventé le bien que de l'arroseur
arrosé
alors il existe une plaque de verre
d'eau au galop mais qui semble
postérieur mais on n'est pas sûr mais
peut-être qu'il y avait encore des gens
avant ce petit scénario là ce petit
script qui n'a l'air de rien quand on le
raconte comme ça accor a été présenté
pour la première fois autant qu'on le
sache qu'on puisse le définir mais ça ça
semble probant dans les pages du flic
doublettes et donc en fait c'est devenu
une espèce de l'histoire de gags comme
ça qu'on dont on retrouve des versions
aussi bien aux états unis qu'en france
même article le faire non pas finie clé
ça va être que
l'inventeur du gag de l'arroseur arrosé
c'est l'inventeur du cuir d'arrosage et
finalement ça va devenir le prototype
même des risques de ce qu'on appelle des
histoires de garnements farceur qui vont
devenir le premier genre
cinématographique aussi c'est à dire que
dans les années 1880 16 1900 le premier
genre cinématographique va partir du
prototype de l'arroseur arrosé et va
multiplier les gags d'une histoire de
bosses qui font des blagues ça va
rebondir dix années dix quinze années
plus tard dans le cinéma burlesque
américain laurent cinéma à la chaplin la
buster keaton et qui est directement
liée à ce type de gamme ont trouvé dans
toutes les dents toutes les bandes
dessinées de l'époque qu'elle est grosse
la vielle elle est plus grosse que papa
peut-on dire ça si mademoiselle non
mademoiselle la vitesse s'accélère et
monsieur fenouillard se cramponne de
plus belle à ne lâche pas
parce qu'en fait le ce qui me plaît je
crois que c'est ça aussi c'est que c'est
de la pure comédie fait avec des du
dessin réaliste et qui nique nique n'est
pas drôle il n'y a pas de ya pas de
caricature il n'y a pas de payer pas de
gros nez il n'y a pas de rails sa douche
pas ça ça tombe pas les profils ces
petits nez en l'air des filles
fenouillard cunégonde et artemis et il a
un sens de latitude sur n'importe quelle
fille est qu'on peut prendre
on comprend tout de suite quel est
l'état d'esprit du personnage je suis
sûr je fais des trucs comme ça à moi
mais inconsciemment leleu parce que ça
me plaise à caen walesa parc lambert qui
s'approche comme ça fait apprendre des
plis pour faire un baiser chaste
c'est du pur excellent jeu de rédacteurs
par les expressions c'est c'est
impeccable
je vise les lui relu et la chef bilingue
mais je renvoie tout ce que je fais ça
par coeur il fait pas le malin avec ce
contrat et je n'ai pas regardé comme je
dessine bien et il se trouve qu'il
dessine pas fait front on sent qu'il ya
pas de dignité dans le nombre de salles
c'est surtout son trait qui est très
novateur
il est comme à la pointe sèche
extrêmement précis il n'y a pas de
lyrisme il ya le geste était très peu
présent
on a l'impression d'un coup d'un
diagramme qui essaie de raconter
l'histoire de à travers l'image la
manière la plus neutre la plus objective
possible
et quand je dessinais quelqu'un
d'arrogant
j'ai malgré moi il ya du christophe qui
ressort l'oeil c'est un petit point à
peine parfois on a l'impression parfois
qu'il n'existe pas mais il est
exactement où il faut il ya une grande
économie de moyens une transparence les
déserts christophe sauf quand ça se
passe de nuit sont vraiment des dessins
comme ça j'allais dire on voit à travers
ils disent nous clairement bien notre
bien d'avoir j'ai même eu cours j'ai
aussi aimé cc je tourne je trouve belle
mais je pense qu alger avait dans l'oeil
aussi très clairement le style très ce
qu'on appelle le skill semi réaliste et
que christophe avait développé à un
point de perfection vraiment très très
particulier alors et cette ligne claire
elle est intéressante d'un point de vue
historique aussi parce que c'est pas la
bande dessinée qu'il invente pendant
tout le xixème siècle les dessinateurs
humoristiques joue avec cette ligne un
peu simple et qui va finalement avoir
une longue histoire dans l'histoire de
la bande dessinée franco belge
les dessins sont plus passifs ils sont
clairs ils sont extrêmement bien
organisé c'est à dire que il ya un jeu
sur la perspective et il est capable de
jouer avec son dessin sur des
expressions simple est de jouer sur le
comment veut dire la variation jouer sur
le rythme il a un sens de l'ellipse
absolument formidable même si c'est très
écrit il ya la façon dont ils coupent
les scènes la façon dont les dialogues
quand ils sont présentés par rapport à
l'image joue soit dans la contradiction
soit dans la surenchère
ça c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
formidable il ya un sens de la litote au
contraire d'exagération qui est que je
trouve vraiment en train tram vraiment
de vous parler des chansons de brassens
il disait écouter les chansons de
brassens sans la musique ce sont de
beaux textes écouter les musiques de
bras ça ce sont de belles musiques mais
ça serait dommage d'en lever l'une à
l'autre
il faut les deux pour que ça marche bien
eh bien je pense que les textes de
christophe sont des textes très drôle
très bien écrit ses dessins sont super
expressif mais c'est l'association de
deux qui rend la chose géniale
si le lecteur était de l'autre côté ils
pourraient constater ce fait d'une haute
portée scientifique le même phénomène
fortuit et inattendue peut produire sur
des physionomie différente la même
expression de désappointement
christophe c'est quelqu'un qui dans son
humour s'intéresse beaucoup au jeu avec
les paradoxes c'est quelqu'un qui
s'intéresse à l'érudition loufoque
c'est quelqu'un qui joue également avec
les problèmes et les solutions
imaginaires et tout ça ce sont des
problèmes qui passionne les katas
physicien la pataphysique c'est qu'un
mot qui paraît peut-être un peu
mystérieux
cet alfred jarry qu'un donne la
définition fait jarry dit que c'est la
science des solutions imaginaires biture
fait venir camembert ça peut vous
appeler une love de creuser un trou pour
un seul fadi m ces ordures et autres
sinon je vous ferai un peu savoir
comment s'appellent camembert qui ne
tient pas à savoir comment s'appelle le
16 janvier sur creuse un trou la fin de
séquence ou camembert va creuser un trou
pour mettre les déchets d'un autre trou
sur vous ou ce que je le mette au dessus
ensuite il va expliquer son désarroi au
sergent bifur je crois qu'ils l'ont
gueule en lui disant mais il fallait
faire un deuxième trou plus grand donc
en termes de logique formelle s'arrête
plus à lewis carroll ou à raymond
queneau c'est absolument génial ça
poserait problème algébrique et de
logique
parlant des trous du sapeur camember
c'est une description effectivement du
processus de conduction électrique dans
certains types de semi conducteurs on
parle de conduction par trou il manque
des électrons quelque part et ce manque
d'électrons et ben se propage d'un
endroit à l'autre du semi conducteur du
donc du cristal
et comme il manque un électron mais ça
fait une charge négative en moins pas
c'est l'équivalent d'une charge positive
en plus et à ce moment là
oh rien d'avoir des électrons qui se
déplacent tout ce passe comme si on
avait des particules positive
this déplacés qui transporte le courant
et ces particules d'un with a pris
naturellement des trous et voilà comment
à ce moment là on veut sapeur camember a
inventé la conduction les conducteurs
dit de type et dans lesquels le courant
est transporté par des trous c'est aussi
simple que ça ne crois pas que presse de
double mulet cornu en fait quatre jours
pour n'avoir pas creusé le deuxième trou
assez grand pour pouvoir y mettre sa
terre avec celle du premier trou
[Musique]
la biennale
évidemment dans ces albums la volonté
d'apprendre des choses de façon amusante
comme dans en flânant à travers la
science est donc pas un moment c'est le
professeur sur ce que georges colomb qui
prend la parole et qui cherche de la
sorte son alter ego de christophe mais
c'est toujours fait de façon subtile et
et amusante
c'est à dire que fenouillard c'est le
type même de la connaissance fausse mal
digérée il a pris des choses à l'école
et les ressorts à tort et à travers
évidemment c'est complètement faux il y
appliquer pelote qui font une enquête et
qui est traduite en termes scientifiques
en même temps c'est un discours sur ce
sont des leçons de physique de chimie
que nous donne christophe en même temps
qu'elle son moral
donc on a un discours voilà comment il
faut pas faire c'est à dire se
précipiter sur des idées soit avec des
préjugés tout faits soit avec l'idée de
tout de suite trouvé une théorie sur le
moindre fait et puis sur ce qu'il faut
faire c'est à dire apprendre
progressivement aller à la rencontre
découvrir étudié colons ce pactole
appelé colombo l'a7 avait garé thater
c'est avant tout un pédagogue mois le
retrouve d'ailleurs la radio ensuite
radio par deux premièrement acheté chez
votre pharmacien
un flacon de 20 depuis le base du daria
de madagascar it al-gamoudi le
champignon excusez moi de m'être emparé
de votre personne avec tant de
brusquerie oran et j'avoue reprisal que
au commencement quand je me suis sentie
garroté dans le réseau serré de vaud
finalement j'ai été choqué du sans-gêne
avec lequel vous vous étiez emparé de ma
personne en oligo temps et trois devant
mais ensuite j'ai senti que la prison
était douce et que mes chaînes étaient
légères
avez vous compris mamie pourquoi vos
chaînes vous semblez légère aux 99 est
que constater le fait mais je serais
heureuse de savoir pourquoi je me sens
si en sécurité chez vous la raison en
est bien simple dit le champignon les
filaments dont je suis fait et qui vous
enveloppe constitue par leur
enchevêtrement même
véritable éponge qui absorbe rapidement
et conservent longtemps l'humidité de
l'air de paris
c'est quelqu'un qui a le sens de la
transmission de la simplification de la
vulgarisation et d'ailleurs à l'époque
où il dessine plus pour les enfants et
continue à écrire des manuels de
vulgarisation je pense pour plusieurs
générations d'enfants
le manuel de sciences naturelles avait
une bonne chance d'être écrit parle
parle lui vous voyez
je l'imaginé goran maigre barbu france
en un ep sourcil sur le cul l'air d'un
microscope et dictant jusqu'à l'aurore
des moules atteint l'idée que ce savant
pu rire même une seule fois mais parle
presque sacrilège lorsqu'un jour mon
père me révéla que collomb s'était
christophe et que christophe c'était
colons ce fut une si grande surprise que
je n'en suis pas encore revenu
ce n'est pas le laboratoire qui a été
son lieu d'expression favori
ça a été plutôt le micro d'une station
de radio ça a été plutôt le collège
sévigné ça a été plutôt le petit
français illustrée donc des endroits où
ils pouvaient s'adresser à un plus large
public et en particulier un public de
jeunes alors nous sommes ici au collège
sévigné qui est un établissement
secondaire rue pierre nicol et georges
colomb sous son vrai nom a enseigné les
sciences naturelles ici de 1896 à 1936
c'est à dire pendant 40 ans alors c'est
quelqu'un qui était très aimée qu'avec
des méthodes pédagogiques assez d'avant
garde encore aujourd'hui puisque au fur
et à mesure qu'il faisait son cours il
destinait sur le tableau tout ce dont il
parlait il était donc extrêmement aimé
par tous ses élèves
donc il ya vraiment leur rôle si vous
voulez un rôle très très très militant
ici disons plutôt plutôt orienté
vers la république c'est à dire à
l'époque ce république c'est la gauche
va être républicain à cette époque c'est
être de gauche et donc finalement
christophe était et est bien ici puisque
effectivement vous savez qu'il a en face
et caradec qui nous a révélé sa qui a
donné des cours particuliers aux enfants
et de dreyfus dont personne ne voulait
la vie est là les cats issus de coups de
poignard qu'il faut savoir boire gotta
go et je le dis hautement pour moi le
coupable est innocent une anecdote qui
se rapportent à l'année je crois en 1918
vous savez qu'il y avait à cette époque
un canon allemand redoutable qu'on après
la grosse bertha encore fait de boules
et de piques et plock un camion un cas
non non non on n'a pas idée et il arrive
à la grosse bertha de donner toute la
nuit donc et parisienne ne pouvais pas
dormir et donc un matin christophe
arrive devant ses élèves
il leur dit mesdemoiselles je pense que
comme moi vous n'avez pas pu dormir
cette nuit
alors dormant et tout le monde a pris sa
tête dans ses mains et s'est mis à
dormir pendant pendant le cours le baron
de cramoisi et leur par mégarde enfoncé
ses éperons d'or le cuir abdominale de
son coursier fidèles celui-ci répondit à
cette attaque imprévu par une
protestation énergie la suite dont on
aperçoit les jambes manifeste son
indifférence
le baron de cramoisi et de plus en plus
mécontents mais il est relativement sec
comme il a l'âme grande et le choeur
noble il montre sa gratitude aux vilains
en l'autorisant à lui servir de
marchepied pour enfourcher son fidèle
courcy
et c'est très violent cramoisi c'est
vrai on a vraiment l'impression que ça
tend vers ce à quoi le chaos
qu'avez vous fait de chrome lite
gratuite des dessous
[Musique]
vous ne recevez pas le baron cramoisi
néanmoins vous illustrer des romans des
fables et des comptes
vous faites aussi du dessin de presse eh
ben dites donc vous est-ce que vous ne
pourriez pas faire appeler attention
nous adversaires de la peine de mort
nous avons fait monter l'outil on va
guillotine est devant vous monsieur le
ministre de la justice
on verrait comme c'est dégoûtant vous
cessé de dessiner des histoires cela ne
vous amusez plus six mais je ne voulais
pas suivre l'exemple de ce qui tire 70
mouture du même sac et les finissent par
faire des horreurs
je n'ai pas voulu me vider
mais ce qui est frappant c'est qu'il va
arrêter ces bandes assez tôt il n'a même
pas 50 ans clairement son inspiration se
tarit ça le fatigue de plus en plus je
dis pas qu'ils passent à autre chose
mais c'est vraiment la vulgarisation
scientifique qui va l'emporter désormais
dans son existence comme si quand même
le sérieux avaient un peu vaincu la
facétie par passion ou part je vous
avais consacré la fin de votre vie à la
recherche du site de la bataille
d'alésia
son dada c'était vercingétorix
ça s'est terminé à sa mort finalement et
il y avait une polémique sur le lieu de
la bataille
alise sainte reine et lui s'entraîne et
alésia
voilà je crois qu'on m'a démontré qu'il
avait eu tort n'aurait pas été content
un buste a même été élevé en votre
honneur dans le petit village de nyon en
franche-comté revient
à son buste mettez qui ressuscita là les
ja comtoise cela vaut mieux en effet que
champion car ce mot champion évoque
l'idée qu'ils aient figuré sur la page
suivante
alors le derrière un georges colomb qui
ressuscita là les ja comtoise 11 août
ce serait peut être mieux choisie c'est
et dites moi ce que vous préférez
elle nous contenterons la bourgeoise
nota bene inutile de sculpter le chien
qui pis est en 45 quand il est mort
avant de décider été installée il ya des
grands auteurs l'énergie on saura jamais
ce qu'il en pensait alors que c'est
quand même un des grands pionniers quoi
chômage
j'aurais aimé savoir ce qu'il a pu en ce
qu'il a pu en penser à l'époque parce
que ce qu'il a initiés quelque chose
mon hypothèse
que colomb ça reste un enfant qui s'est
arrêtée à 10 12 ans et a continué à
faire plaisir à l'enfant qui était en
lui les pieds nickelés la bande dessinée
en général et pour certain christophe a
occupé un certain rôle c'est là que ça
aussi nourri l'imaginaire d'un homme
peut pas mal de chemin
à qui
dans l'est du pont ce costume à la
chinoise s'est déjà dans la famille
fenouillard donc livré semblable il ya
comme ça une influence qui passent de
génération en génération
[Musique]
le rapport c'est ironique qui a dans la
la parole par rapport à une image qui ne
dit pas exactement la même chose ça a
été déclencheur complètement de mon
envie de raconter des histoires vous
arrive-t-il de relire vos livres me
livre mais il m'amuse d'autant plus que
j'ai oublié ce qu'il ya dedans tous les
gosses savent le nom de l'appareil avec
lequel savants cosinus voulait sortir de
paris pas moi vous parlez de l'année les
mails etc trop réguler pédales et
coupe-vent trombe à 0 par aclu cycle
[Musique]
ceux qui viennent ici me lapp rennes et
je l'oubli aussitôt je n'ai jamais pu
retenir le diable de mots plus ou moins
magique qu'il faut prononcer pour
arrêter les saignements de nez
oui à derrick à rabastens varades à
patara ce qu'il va dans le travail
c'est une rentrée
[Musique]